okay so
again uh you move into the in space you
only enter into the in space okay so
you're not y y clashing okay so he go he
goes he does Mount
reversal and he's going to want to
posture up okay and start working his
escapes and preventions and things like
that
okay well that creates the in space so I
am already looking as I feel like whoa
whoa okay and he gets it come on and I
he got me okay I'm already looking
for that space you see and I'm already
looking for that arm to do the pendulum
okay so
again or this balloon sweep so as
sorry stay
connected you're like okay you already
lost it and now start looking for it so
you can go with
him okay
notot
here
boom you go and now you're you're not
going to get it okay you have to go with
the timing opening he goes you already
feel you lost it like pull it and start
chasing
it is that
really try it again
okay see if you can shorten that don't
go dead like that right
go all right so slow back down he's
going right about here I I know oh he
got it I'm going to lose this okay what
I'm talking about is just let go of it
then you didn't lose it okay and now I
start looking for this arm you see I
don't let him grab onto it or anything
okay so I already made the connection go
back
see he has the walk comes around and
here's where I traded position I'm
keeping that arm away from grabbing it's
as good as in the admin position if
someone puts it on the ground okay and
now I start start working with his
energy so I don't go now it's as he
slowly is going up that's where I start
to follow it follow that energy okay and
once you get here don't go for that
turn take his Center rout first ever so
slightly boom and now go for the
turn
Okay destructure him by pushing his
Center out of his posture okay try it
again all right we'll start at the
bottom okay so I got
here and realize that uh this hip bump
sweep it works best if he goes all the
way up
okay and then realize too that uh as he
feels you coming up he might not go all
the way up so he starts to push down you
see well that's where you have
all those things that we were working on
okay so here I have goo here's my elbow
right these two the igami and the hip
bump they play off each other if he's
anywhere in this area with this hand off
the ground good that arms isolated and
exposed if he counts so for example if I
try for that one and he postur up you're
going to have a hard time getting it but
that's what opens up the hip bump okay
so they play off each other if I'm
trying for the hip bump and he starts to
posture down then you ATT the arm cuz
he's coming back forward
okay so if you're
finding U from here my guy's not going
up high enough just go for the Kimura
it's not there he's going to counter it
then you follow that up
okay by sticking with
him all right put it together you can
work either the arm or the uh hip bump
sweep go start it start again at the
bottom so again as as he's here and uh
he starts to go up I'm entering into the
y space he if he resist on me like he's
pushing back okay don't I won't keep
going I go ahead and attack the arm and
go where he's going okay okay I moved
myself out so if he can't get his if if
he's really resisting there and he can't
I can't get his shoulder down right then
I'll Attack the
wrist here or I'll Attack the elbow here
okay if I get them all the way down then
I go to the shoulder
lock
likewise if I'm going here and we come
around and he's really strong he
overpowers his right hand it's
straightening his arm that around the
arm and trap it on my neck okay and
don't make this like rocket
science you you have a a joint here okay
I want to always be at the tricep tendon
of Insertion I want to be perpendicular
to it and I want to use something that's
hard there okay and I want to use my
body so I can do the left
arm you can do this one none of this
stuff
matters okay okay so I usually end up
here or I end up
here so we'll go
back I couldn't go into the hip bump
he's too strong I'm not going to fight
him so he now exposes the arm I take the
arm he fights it I go around the arm and
he falls into the elbow
lock and it's so seamless that most
people don't even know he wasn't trying
for any of that stuff okay I was trying
for the hip BM
okay all right try it again